[Music]
this has really been amazing this has
been a deal three years in the making
Vegas we get so many horror fans that
come from all over the world and they
they come into town and they want to
experience things like this and what's
fun about these ones is it's not just
October it is open year-round five days
a week saws open the same Blair which is
open the same and I'm not done yet you
know I've got four years of work backed
up right now we're gonna we're gonna
create some amazing things we are
actually in the iconic neighborhood
house so we spent 14 months building the
all-new Escape it and because we spent
so much time on it everything has really
transpired over to the guests perfectly
so
unlike you know something that you throw
together in six months you know you
don't know what's gonna work or not we
actually spent the last 30 days testing
this thing out so we could take out
puzzles that didn't work with the guests
so the guests are coming out of here
shock
it is just so big it's 16 different
rooms that you have to escape and it is
unbelievable the scenes match the movie
Perfectly the scenes are huge I mean
this is by far the biggest escape room
in the world
I'm so excited with the reactions we've
had so far we're actually standing by
the real Three Doors from the actual
films right here so not only do we have
this we've got props from the actual
movie which is unbelievable we've got
the bikes running away we've got the
three doors from the movie and we have
all kinds of other fun props from
chapter one and chapter two that Warner
Brothers was so kind to let us borrow so
we've got a whole Midway Arcade in here
we've got a full retail store I mean we
found the perfect building for this so
we could fit everything in this we
possibly could and then we've got
chapter two opening in the next couple
months as well too so this has really
been amazing
you know I love horror and as long as
the fans and the locals keep coming to
us we're to keep creating more cool
stuff